i miss
physical intimacy with him i'm not ever
going to be in a conjugal relationship
with her because i'm not going to go
through that emotional torture ever
again mary and cody brown aren't holding
back when it comes to talking about
their sex life or the lack thereof
there's a point where intimacy is just
damage
it's it's misleading
it's it's a to have intimacy in a
relationship where
there
there is
no real safety
ooh
yeah
i'm not going there
during part one of the sister wives
tell-all cody and his four wives mary
janel christine and robin open up to
host sukanya krishnan about their
family's ups and downs in particular
mary gets candid about her relationship
with her husband and how it's changed
since adding three wives to the mix
when janelle came into the picture it
was a struggle for me
because now he's
with somebody else was it jealousy was
it did you not know how to manage it of
course of course there's jealousy people
ask all the time i think all three of us
had different ideals going into it of
how it was going to be fans will recall
in 2015 mary was involved in a
catfishing scandal i thought i was
talking to a man online
it wasn't a man
it was
a woman
pretending to be a man the issue caused
a falling out with cody and put a huge
strain on their relationship i would
love it if he would hold my hand yeah
you know but that's just not where we
are i will be her friend
i will do what i can to protect her
we'll build a house for her out on
coyote pass but i'm never going to feel
safe in an intimate place and that
wasn't from the catfishing
it was just the catfish just woke me up
out of the
out of the days i guess
but despite their lack of intimacy the
tlc star reveals she has no plans of
leaving i don't understand people who
think well just because you don't have
this relationship with cody
why don't you just leave why don't you
just leave like because i don't want to
from where i am like
it's been like 31 years now that you
know we've been married and you know i'm
still committed
i've
made my choice and although cody and
mary legally divorced in 2016 he told et
last year he's in it for life if our
relationship isn't good then we either
figure out how to work it out or or
whatever i don't even know what that
looks like we've been doing counseling
for
seven years you know we don't allow the
d word in the house
well not out of my mouth necessarily i
don't see that on the horizon here
i don't see that as part of my life but
mary isn't the only sister wife
struggling with her marriage during the
tell-all christine also spoke her truth
cody and i've been having such a rough
time for so long but it's really hard to
be in a room with everybody and watch
him be incredible in other relationships
and know that your own is terrible and
wonder what am i supposed to do the two
reality stars announced the end of their
25-year spiritual marriage in november
mary i can't do marriage with cody
anymore i don't want to you don't get to
give up like that i don't want to do it
anymore
this season fans have watched their
rocky relationship play out i'm not okay
with staying in a marriage where there's
no intimacy that's not a real marriage
we are going to go to aspen mitch's for
thanksgiving
but we will be here for christmas
i really like living separate i like my
own space i like my own autonomy i feel
like i like me better now but there's
one thing christine is enjoying at the
moment being a grandma the mother of six
shared this sweet pic of her
granddaughter avalon on instagram
writing in part quote it's so rewarding
watching your children become incredibly
amazing parents and then getting this
wonderful bundle of love along with it
and when eti spoke with christine last
year when her daughter mykelty was
pregnant with little avalon she couldn't
hold back her excitement i'm so excited
for another grand baby coming for all of
us um it's been fun so i actually we had
a
outdoor baby shower for her and we are
able to keep it all outside in her home
in st george like outside her home in st
george so i traveled down there to see
her and spend some time with her and it
was absolutely wonderful
[Music]